wow
such a quiet day nothing going on here
come on come on guys here
yeah please I love it
good afternoon everybody
come on there's a lot of people here
good afternoon everybody
okay so as you can all see we have a
couple of special guests here today in
the briefing room I am proud so proud to
Welcome to the podium coach Steve Kerr
hello
head coach of the Golden State Warriors
and nine-time NBA champion as both a
coach and a player and Steph Curry
four-time NBA champion and two-time NBA
most valuable player coach Kerr and and
Steph will say a few words about their
visit to DC today and an issue that's
close to their hearts and so I'm going
to let them take over but you know I I
almost coach I almost went pro
but you know being five foot two five
foot three didn't make it happen but
there's this great video of me and Sue
bird an amazing icon in the Caribbean
Bay you should check that out but anyway
I'm gonna let you guys take over yeah
thank you very much yeah thank you so
much uh for having us today on behalf of
the Warriors I want to thank President
Biden and vice president Harris for the
invitation to come to the White House
today to celebrate our Championship from
a year ago
um it's a great reminder of how lucky we
are to be Americans to live in a country
where we can uh chase our dreams and and
enjoy
um the the fruits of our labor and the
celebration of all those around us and
to come here today with members of the
organization to to celebrate is really
something special I was also a very
fulfilling for me just a little while
ago to take part in a round table on gun
violence and gun safety
with some senior White House staffers
along with Clay Thompson and Moses Moody
over the last hour or so we learned a
lot about what this Administration is
doing to to help create a safer
environment in our country as something
that's very close to my heart and it's
wonderful for me to to learn a lot more
than than I knew so coming in today is
uh it's a it's a great day on many
fronts so thanks for the invitation and
I'm going to turn it over to Mr Curry
thanks coach uh Echo what he said I want
to thank uh President Biden vice
president Harris for the invitation to
come here it's uh something that we
don't ever take for granted uh seven
years ago I believe we were here last
celebrating our first championship and
now back to celebrate our fourth so to
have this opportunity to reflect on the
accomplishment last year to bring
everybody together to celebrate that to
also acknowledge the the play sports has
and bringing people together from all
walks of life all backgrounds
to provide inspiration hope love
togetherness and that's what our journey
was last year so to have another
opportunity to celebrate that means a
lot and a great opportunity for us from
the basketball Community to thank
President Biden and his staff for all
their hard work and diligence on getting
Brittany Greiner home is a big part of
our basketball family and uh it means a
lot to know that she's here and home
safe with her family and all the work
that went on behind the scenes to make
that a reality so uh just want to say
thank you there and uh very excited to
be here and celebrate the Day celebrate
with our families and I appreciate the
invitation this is a truly truly special
so thank you to everybody
thank you so much thank you thank you
thanks thank you so much no questions
no they have they have a they as you can
imagine they have a tight schedule I
think they're on their way to meet with
the president right now and then as you
know you'll some of you will get to see
uh the two of them and the rest of the
team uh at the event that we're having
for the Warriors in about an hour or
less than an hour okay folks uh thank
you so much for joining us today and uh
it was great to hear from two people who
have really been passionate voices uh on
the issue that you heard them talk about
which was gun violence prevention and we
really really are thankful to them for
using their platform they're very very
big platform to talk about an issue that
is truly as you all know and report that
is destroying many families across the
country many communities and as you know
that the president has worked and been a
leader on for many decades and this uh
the bipartisan gun prevention bill that
was signed this summer just showed the
president's commitment to this issue and
as you all know it continues it doesn't
stop with that legislation on Friday
it was reported that Republicans have
so-called plan to prioritize payments if
Congress fails to address the debt
ceiling
so I want to be very very clear here as
I have been as the president has been
this is not a plan it is a recipe for
economic catastrophe as President Biden
has made clear Congress must deal with
the debt limit and must do so without
conditions but Congressional Republicans
are threatening to hold the nation's
full faith and credit a mandate of the
Constitution Hostage to their demands to
cut Social Security to cut Medicare and
to cut Medicaid brinksmanship that
threatens the global economy
their latest idea is that rather than
paying its bills the United States
should make payment to wealthy
bondholders including foreign investors
and stop payments for border security
food safety nursing home school lunches
the FAA drug enforcement and other
programs Americans rely on every single
day
the so-called prioritization scheme
makes Republicans priorities pretty
clear crystal clear if I may add they
want to put wealthy bondholders over
ordinary Americans who want safe foods
safe Skies safe communities and secure
borders and it does not it does nothing
absolutely nothing to change the fact
that failing to deal with the debt limit
would cause economic catastrophe
bipartisan former Treasurer secretaries
and independent experts have called out
how dangerous failing to raise the debt
ceiling would be it for example I'll
give you a couple the Chamber of
Commerce said it would have catastrophic
Economic Consequences end quote in 2011
then treasury secretary Tim Geithner
called it unworkable and also harmful
and a former Economist to Republican
Senators Rob Portman Marco Rubio and
Mitt Romney called it really bad idea
and I quote disaster
this is just another attempt by
Congressional Republicans to force
unpopular cuts on programs critical to
seniors the middle class and Working
Families Congress needs to act and do so
swiftly there is no excuse for political
brinksmanship when American jobs and
economic safety is on the line here
I also wanted to highlight that this
morning the White House released the
first ever National strategy to advance
Equity Justice and opportunity for Asian
Americans native Hawaiian and Pacific
Islander communities
the strategy details much needed
investment from 32 federal agencies
including improved data language access
and combating anti-asian hate this
unprecedented plan Builds on the
administration's broader Equity agenda
and President Biden's historic executive
order to establish and reinvigorate the
White House initiative on a a and nhpis
and we're proud that the Biden Harris
Administration reflects the rich
diversity of America including the first
Asian American vice president 14 percent
of our appointees and nominees identify
as a a and a n h p i double the share of
the population you can read the full
strategy and more about the initiative
on the whitehouse.gov and finally this
morning as some of you have have already
uh either covered or wrote about a
Census Bureau release data that showed
that President Biden's first two years
in office have been the two greatest
years for new small business
applications on record with 10.5 million
total new business created with
unemployment at a record low and the two
strongest years of job creation in our
history there are reasons for economic
optimism all over the country today's
new data is the latest confirmation that
President Biden's economic plan is
indeed working and is building our
economy from the bottom up and the
middle out Zeke you want to take it
Experian uh two questions for you let me
start off with um over the weekend uh
British government participating tanks
to Ukraine for the first time will the
U.S follow suit grants request there and
then separately prime minister
Richardson it is you know very antiqui
alluded potentially joining the U.S and
Germany and sending a patriotism system
Ukraine can you confirm it that was the
announcement that's coming out of the
meeting we haven't gotten to read that
yet okay so we're going to have a
readout very very shortly so once we
have that I will share that with all we
will share the team we'll share that
with all of you uh as far as uh Patriot
missiles
um I can say they discussed that the war
in Ukraine and the importance of all uh
the ongoing security assistance but I I
would refer to Dutch for any specifics
about their own plans as it relates to
that specifically as it relates to the
conversation on I'm sorry I forgot the
first question
so look we are always very
um uh very careful on what uh on on what
are you know we don't like to to to tell
our allies what they should or should
not do but as you know we have been we
have been partners with them when it
comes to you Ukraine partners with our
allies and partners with them on how we
are continuing to provide assistance to
Ukraine in this aggressive war that we
have saw we have seen this brutal war
that we continue to see by Russia but
certainly that is not something that we
will direct we will continue to focus we
have been the country that has provided
the most assistance as you all know when
it comes to security assistance when it
comes to humanitarian Aid and we are in
constant conversations with Ukraine on
what their needs are and and so we're
going to continue to do that alongside
our partners and also our allies
the UK is going to be ahead of the US
and in Western tanks to Ukraine they're
going ahead listening more than a dozen
of them in the coming weeks and months
the White House still hasn't approved
that so is that in the office now for
the US to Leap Frog head back into the
leading providing assistance for Ukraine
again look we are in constant
conversation with the Ukrainian with the
ukrainians on um on their assistance we
have given the most assistance in any
other country the president when he
walked into the administration he made
sure that he brought the NATO together
he brought our alliance and partners
together to make sure that we we had the
backs of the Ukrainian people and so
that is something that we're going to
continue to do uh certainly I'm not
going to get ahead of any announcements
from here but again this is uh we will
be with the Ukrainian people for as long
as it takes for them to defend
themselves so for them to defend
themselves against the brutal uh the
brutality that we are seeing from the
Russian aggression a different topic of
writing the discovery classified in the
official documents of the president's
residence in the former office last week
you told everyone it was still that we
all can assume American people could
assume that the searches were complete
and all the documents had been recovered
uh on Saturday the White House counsel's
Office uh said that five additional
classified documents had been found is
it safe to assume now that all the
documents are uh have been recovered all
the official records all the classified
documents are back in the custody of the
National Archives or more searches on
your way to find out if there's anything
else there look I I understand your
question we have addressed multiple
questions from here multiple questions
have been answered by the president I
know that you all just spent about some
of you some of your colleagues maybe you
yourself seek was was on the phone with
my colleague for about 45 minutes that
addressed a lot of your questions I'm
just going to continue to be prudent
here I'm going to let this ongoing
review that is happening this legal
process that is happening uh and and let
that let that process continue under the
special counsel we're not I'm not going
to comment from here I'm not one of the
things that we have said for the last
two years when it comes to the
Department of Justice when it comes to
legal matters when it comes to legal
issues we have been very clear that we
are not going to comment we are not
going to politically interfere and uh
and that continues with this also this
legal issue and so I would refer you to
the Department of Justice refer you to
the special counsel as it relates to
specifics on this issue and also my
White House Council colleagues are
engaging with all of you and will
certainly continue to have a
conversations on this I will say that we
are consistent with what we have said on
cooperating fully with the Department of
Justice on this issue and we will
continue to cooperate fully with the
special counsel I think it's great on
Friday you stood here though and were
asked about this documents issued by our
accounts on 18 times at that point the
president's lawyers had found these five
additional pages of classified documents
so did you not know on Friday that those
documents have been found when you were
at the podium or are you being directed
by someone to not be forthcoming
honestly I'm I have been forthcoming
from this Podium what I uh said yes to
was what the statement at the time that
we all had right you all had the
statement uh and I was repeating what
the what the council was sharing at that
time and so we had that statement so we
knew what was in it but you also exactly
knew did you not know that I'm telling
you I just answered the question I just
said that I was repeating what the
information that we had at that time
right that you all had I was confirming
from what the special Counsel had
provided to all of you and that we knew
as well from here so just to be very
very clear uh and look I've also been
very clear about being prudent from here
I was also being very clear about being
consistent from here and not going uh
beyond what is currently happening right
and again this is an ongoing I also said
this was an ongoing uh review that was
happening with the Department of Justice
and as we know with the special counsel
I've been very consistent about that as
well and that's one of the reasons your
question to me is one of the reasons why
I'm I we are being very very careful and
very Mindful and to not interfere here
and to make sure to make sure that
department of justice has their
independence your question actually
proves that and that's why we're going
to continue to refer you to Department
of Justice and refer you to the special
counsel or my colleagues
at White House Council does President
Biden have confidence in the way his
team is handling this with this trickle
out of information and the documents
being found day after day I can tell you
this the president has confidence I can
tell you this that the president and his
team uh rightfully took action when they
learned that the documents existed they
reached out to the archives they reached
out to the Department of Justice that is
the steps we have been very clear about
that the steps in the process that we
took here uh and uh and look we're going
to continue we're going to continue to
as we have said fully cooperate with the
Department of Justice we're going to
fully cooperate with the president's
team is going to fully cooperate with
the special counsel that does not stop
and that will just continue again we're
going to respect the independence of the
Department of Justice right he's new to
us and the conversations you've had with
him on this issue his mood has been very
clear I I saw him this morning he's very
focused I was with I traveled with him
this weekend he wants to make sure that
he's continuing and we are continuing to
deliver for the American people and
we've been you know we've been pretty
consistent on that if you think about
last week you heard from him about how
his economic plan is working how we have
seen inflation go down for six months
straight how we have seen uh
unemployment unemployment numbers at its
lowest level in 50 years that matters
that is also the things that this
country the people in this country are
also very very concerned about and want
to hear what this President is doing
every day that's his focus and that's
what he's going to continue to talk
about go ahead Steve what's the White
House reaction to the news in the knee
Pro where the Russians bomb their
Department building and killed civilians
so look this weekend strikes are another
example as you've heard us say of the
brutal and barbaric war that Russia is
waging against the Ukrainian people and
we have seen this over and over again
for about 10 months now 11 months now
the United States will continue to
provide as I said at the top Ukraine
with what it needs to defend itself that
is incredibly important that is a
promise that the president made to
president zielinski when he was here not
too long ago and that's including air
defense system along with our allies and
partners as I just said we will continue
our work to hold Russians forces
accountable for the atrocities that
they've caused and also the war crimes
but one of the things that we continue
to see Russia do is that they
underestimate the strength and the
courage and the resolve of the Ukrainian
people and they will be proven wrong
again in their latest attempts the debt
ceiling is supposed to reach its ceiling
on Thursday how do you see the debt
ceiling fight playing out what's your
strategy for getting an agreement so
look we have been very clear on this and
I said it at the top I said it on Friday
and I'll say it today so has the
president this should not be political
brinksmanship we should be dealing with
the debt ceiling without without
conditions it is important we're not
going to work our way around this we're
not going to negotiate on this this is
the basic the basic duties of Congress
is to deal with this issue and let's not
forget in the last Administration they
they meaning Democrats and Republicans
were able to deal with the debt limit uh
three times three times so this is
something that needs to be done that
should be done and we call on Congress
to act lastly is the president going to
sit down with Republicans and talk about
this again this is something that should
be done without conditions we have been
very very clear about that we are not
going to be negotiating over the debt
ceiling but I'll say this more broadly
at the start of the new Congress and I
actually spoke about this last week
we're reaching out to all members in
both parties to build relationships and
establish points of contact that is
something that the office of ledge
Affairs has done for the past couple of
weeks but you know this has been done
when you talk about the debt ceiling it
has been done in a bipartisan way and
there should be bipartisan cooperation
to address this it should not be a
political football this should not be a
political football and we should do it
without conditions okay Phil did not
come to the back the president's team
had a strategy list of goals heading
into this year is there any concern that
that may be kind of overtaken by what's
been happening in the force in the last
week with the investigation
I mean I just talked about last week uh
What uh what we saw about with the
economic plan we saw the CPI data and
it's showing that inflation is indeed
going down because of the president's
Economic Policy we have seen the
president do uh bipartisan work bring
both sides together when you think about
going to the bridge in Kentucky and you
saw that for yourselves how the
president was able to bring both sides
together to talk about an issue that was
so important for that region in Kentucky
to talk about infrastructure something
that many presidents before this
president had tried to do and were not
able to do it in the last Administration
it was a punch line it was a joke when
we talked about infrastructure week and
now under this President we've been able
to do it in a bipartisan way look we're
going to continue to do the work we're
going to have uh Mayors here in a couple
of days we'll share more information
about that event and president will talk
to to then about the work that we are
doing and the work that we're going to
continue for the American people we went
to Mexico City just about a week ago we
were in Mexico City feels like two weeks
ago but yes we were in Mexico City about
a week ago and you saw the president on
the world stage talking to our closest
Partners in North America about how
we're going to deal with issues that
matter to the American people and you
saw the friendly engagement you saw how
successful uh the nulls the nals of that
Summit was and so that's not going to
stop the president he is very much
focused on what are we going to do to
lower cost what are we going to do to
continue to lower costs what are we
going to do to continue to deliver for
the American people and let me add to
what Republicans are putting forward
House Republicans the extreme members of
the House the Maga Republicans are
talking about raising taxes for
middle-class Americans they're talking
about giving a tax break for the
wealthiest Among Us that's what they
want to do they're talking about
attacking women's rights to choose
that's what they want to put forward and
the present is going to speak against
that as well and try to make sure that
we deliver for the American people we
can do both
Mr President
but given the limitations given what
you've talked about through the podium
that we shouldn't expect the president
to give his thoughts or opinions
and you just said it's an ongoing matter
right this is an ongoing legal uh
process that's happening currently and
we are going to continue what we've been
doing for the last two years which is
when it comes to the Department of
Justice when it comes to legal issues we
will not comment we are going to be
prudent from here we are not going to
political inter politically interfere
because one of the things that the
president was very clear during the
campaign and has been for the last two
years is that we want to give back the
the Independence that the Department of
Justice has go ahead Peter
just to follow up if I can very quickly
on this the White House says Republicans
are faking outrage on this issue why
shouldn't Americans be outraged about
classified documents being found in a
garage
look
and I think I've been very clear about
this we have answered questions on this
at this Podium you've heard as Phil was
saying twice from the president talk
about this he said that he didn't know
right he said that he was surprised and
he said that he takes classified
information and documents very very
seriously we heard directly from the
president on this issue now anything
else anything beyond that we're just not
going to talk about there's an
investigation going on there's a legal
process here as we've been very very
clear about I will let the White House
counsel talk about any specific details
about that but we're going to be prudent
here and make sure that we are not
interfering in this process I guess
that's why I'm asking though because
you've said that you don't want to
interfere here and be prudent about the
process but the White House did post a
statement saying that Republicans are
faking outrage So to that point why
shouldn't Americans be upset about
documents found in a garage that's for
uh that's for the American people to
decide right that is for you all or I'm
sure going to talk to many folks out
there and have that this conversation
but what we do know right what we do
know from polling that we have seen over
and over again from your coverage uh
from what we hear what the president
goes out and talk to the talks to the
American people they also care about the
economy right they also care about what
is the president doing to lower costs
which is why he took hysteric historic
action in making sure that gas prices
went down at the gas pump and we saw
that happen by more than a buck 70 cents
and that's the work that the president's
going to focus on you think about the
inflation reduction at that's going to
lower lower prescription drug cost lower
medical costs right when you think about
that lower energy costs so that's going
to be our Focus here we know that's what
the American people truly care about as
well and it is very important for them
that we do that work I'm going to try
and go to the back okay thank you
um just back on the tanks
uh it seems that everybody's talking
about tanks the last few days uh in
Europe there's been a bunch of countries
saying that I wanted to give tanks or
people should give tanks and then the
Germans are being you know on the fence
about it everyone's talking about it
nothing's actually happening apart from
the Brits of course I'm not part of the
European Union uh the president's
position himself as you know the leader
of this whole Alliance pretty much right
um is this a moment when he feels maybe
he should step in as the leader and
either you know cajole or you probably
wouldn't want to use that word but you
know talk to the Germans or go with the
U.S tanks the Abrams it's something
that'll happen and you know in shortly
because it feels like a bit of a boiling
point so a couple of things here um and
it the president's view hasn't changed
uh and I kind of said it when I was
answering Zeke's question which is he
believes that it's up to uh each country
to make their own Sovereign decisions
here on what types of security assistant
and what kinds of equipment they're able
to provide Ukraine as Ukraine defends
itself against Russia's brutal uh brutal
aggression for instance we welcome
Germany's recent announcement that they
will send infantry fighting vehicles and
Patriot missiles battery system to
Ukraine we also support the decision by
the UK as I was asked over the weekend
to send Challenger tanks to Ukraine we
welcome that we have seen incredible
solidarity by Nations around the world
to support Ukraine and uh and also I
know that secretary Austin is hosting
another meeting of the Ukrainian of the
Ukraine Conte Tech group that was just
happening just this Friday this week and
we look forward to further discussions
on how this broad Coalition of allies
and partners can continue to support
Ukraine as Russia continues again
continues this brutal war and barbaric
war against the Ukrainian people but
again as I said at the top you know we
uh it's up to each country to make their
own decisions on this
look again when it comes to when it
comes to these types of security
assistance decision it is up to each
country to make that decision and we
leave it to them
given these documents have shown up in
very personal spaces we all know that
the president loves his Delaware owners
of extremely personal space fan is he
physically joining in the search these
things rummaging around you know these
boxes in the garage and wherever else I
mean literally are you are you are you
listening to your the question that
you're asking me
seriously look seriously I mean okay
look in searching for example look I'm
gonna be very consistent here uh I am
going to be very clear here as I have
been for the past couple of days almost
a week now uh dealing with this uh you
know we are going to any specific
questions that you have about this issue
I would refer you to my colleagues at
the White House counsel's Office who
spent almost an hour taking these
questions from all of you many of your
colleagues I'ma let you ask that
question to the White House counsel's
office and anything else specific to
this I refer you to Department of
Justice I refer you to special counsel
okay
um on month if it's raining um on Monday
in regards to police shootings the
president said um I think I did the only
thing I can do is it the opinion of the
White House that there will be no more
progress on the issue of police reform
going forward that there's just nothing
more to do
Luke the president has been very clear
in asking Congress to take action he has
taken executive action I'm sure you've
covered a lot of the uh actions that
he's taken the past two years and he
believes it's uh it's it's now in the
hands of Congress to take action uh and
it is important to do uh just that and
I'll leave it there
one more step and Curry up for the first
name basis now apparently I know buddies
you guys are but they don't even let me
call them Stephen Curry uh he mentioned
the bring of Brittany Greiner but does
the White House have any comment on the
attention of CM at namazi who's in Iran
and uh on the on hunger strike and sent
a letter to the president so we received
the letter and our thoughts are with um
uh namazi and his family we remain
committed to securing his freedom and
the US government is continuing to work
to bring him home along with U.S
citizens who are wrongfully detained in
Iran including Imad chagri and Murad
tabas Iran's use of wrongful detention
as political Leverage is outrageous the
U.S will always stand for our citizens
overseas we've been very clear about
that and committed you've seen the
president take action and you've heard
the president say that directly one of
our highest priorities is bringing all
of our wrongfully detained citizens home
safely as soon as possible and resolving
the cases of missing and abducted U.S
citizens so this will continue to be a
priority for the American people for the
president
does the White House have any reaction
to the U.S in New Mexico of a former
Republican candidate for the State House
there who was allegedly organizing men
to shoot at the homes of four Democratic
elected officials uh don't have a
comment on on that at this time I heard
the stories I just need to check with
the team to get the full rundown but I
don't have a comment at this time on
that okay
I'm gonna follow up on Cecilia's
question and sorry if I missed it but on
Friday did you or did you not know about
the additional I already I literally
just answered that question
so is it yes or no I mean you're you're
not too far sitting next to her so I was
very clear I provided I provided the
information that you all had at the time
no I did not know I'm saying I had the
information I actually said this to
Cecilia I had the information that you
all had at the time right and so this is
why I also said to Cecile this is why we
are trying to be very prudent here and
we're trying to be very consistent and
say this is an ongoing legal process and
this is why I say we're just not going
to comment from here that is a perfect
example in Cecilia's question and I was
very clear about that when did you learn
about the documents found at the Penn
Center in November and in Wilmington in
December when your team was in was doing
a story
got it because I was also asked a
similar question about if our team has
been engaged on this and I've been very
clear this is something that the White
House Council is handling this is
something that is being handled by the
president's lawyers have been very clear
that's why we are this is why we are
being prudent here this is why we're
being consistent with what we have done
the last two years when it comes to doj
Department of Justice investigation we
are just not going to interfere
on that note you've repeatedly
emphasized the need just as you did
today for Independence for integrity
um of the Department of Justice
investigation one reason why you
continue to point us to the doj so I
wonder why then did the White House
counsel
go to Wilmington to facilitate the
handing over of documents to the doj
that is
I appreciate the questions I know
there's going to continue to be dozens
more questions probably today and I will
say
reach out to the White House counsel's
Office that's one of the reasons my
colleague was on the phone with many of
you taking questions today and I'm just
going to leave it there that is
something for them to answer
it's related to something that you keep
telling us which is how much it is
important to this White House to
separate the White House from the doj's
investigation but the White House
Council was the one to go and facilitate
the documents to look for the documents
again they have been working very
closely with the Department of Justice I
would refer you to them if you want to
know specifically about their actions
specifically about what they're doing I
would point you to the White House
counsel's Office look guys you guys can
ask me this a hundred times 200 times if
you wish I'm going to keep saying the
same thing I hear your question it's
been asked it's been answered it's been
noted and we're just going to try to
move on here and we're going to move on
one more because Ian did have that call
today and he said that the White House
would quote fully cooperate with the
investigation does that mean that
President Biden is willing to be
interviewed if caught up I'm just not
gonna you're asking a question that
should go to the White House council's
office as you just said Ian you spoke to
to my colleague just moments ago that is
something that the White House counsel's
office should be answering any anything
specific to the doj or special counsel
uh
what they're doing you need to reach out
to them go ahead Tim yeah um are you
upset that you came out to this Podium
on Friday with incomplete and inaccurate
information and are you concerned that
it affects your credibility up here well
what I'm what I'm concerned about is
making sure that we do not politically
interfere in the Department of Justice
that we continue to be consistent over
the last two years and uh and that is
continue to refer you all when it comes
to an ongoing process
and uh and I'll just leave it there and
let's not forget there was actually a
statement from the council's office that
you all had at the same time as well I'm
I'm just not going to go down uh Eddie
Rabbit Hole here I'm going to be very
consistent I'm going to be very prudent
and uh again I've been asked just ask
that question I've answered it it's been
noted the question and we're just going
to move on go ahead JJ thanks so just to
clarify that debt ceiling again so the
White House has no intention of sitting
down with leader McCarthy on the debt
ceiling in the coming month or and at
all what we're saying here is that
um we've been very very clear it was
clear at the top it was clear when I was
just asked this question Congress is
going to need to address the debt
without conditions and and it's just
that simple this should not be there
should be no hostas shaking here uh
there should be no attempts to exploit
the debt ceiling or to to leverage it
we're going to be very very uh clear
about that and again and I said this
before this was done three times under
the last uh Administration in a
bipartisan way this is the duty of
Congress this is something that is their
basic duty to deal with the debt ceiling
and so we're going to continue to be
consistent here about that and again
there should be no it should not be used
as a political football
regular accurately report that the white
house isn't doing any Outreach to
Republicans about this no I I have said
I said just moments ago one of the
things that we did and I laid this out
uh pretty clearly when the new Congress
started we reached out to Republicans
and Democrats alike uh to talk about who
their point of contact is to have that
conversation to figure out how we're
going to work together and so I've I've
there is constant conversations
happening uh with uh with members of
Congress and their and their team that
is something that we are doing almost on
a certainly a weekly uh basis and that
always is going to happen those
conversations are always going to happen
I'm certainly not going to read out
every conversation that we're having uh
with uh with Congressional members or
Congressional staff what I am saying is
that we have been very clear that this
should be done we're talking about the
debt ceiling it should be done without
conditions and it should not be used as
a political football
okay
um just wanted to go back to the the
bilat earlier and the one last week with
the Prime Minister of Japan these are
two countries that are huge players in
the semiconductor chain have you made
any progress in getting those countries
to join the efforts that the U.S has
started to restrict China's access to
those semiconductors to that technology
so I just want to be very clear on this
as well we don't push any of our allies
or our partners we consult with them
closely and they make their own
decisions and this is how we we move
forward with our relationship again with
our allies and partners we all recognize
the importance of this issue to to
National Security and the president did
discuss it along with a host of other
important Regional and Global issues
look this is going to be a continuing
part of a group consultation here and I
don't have any announcements to make or
anything further to share on this but
does the president feel that the U.S can
be successful in preventing China from
getting that technology if these types
of countries like the Netherlands like
Japan don't join even if it's not
exactly the same restrictions but don't
join in those types of efforts again
we're just not going to push our
partners and allies here I again the
president it did come up in their
conversation I'm just not going to uh
getting into
a specific conversations of what
happened or what was said what we
believe is that our close allies and
partners make their own decisions on
these types of things
okay is there a bipartisan plan for our
youth today do we have a focus on either
education are we looking at I just
wanted to soften the mood a little bit
in the room but is there anything that
we're focusing on in terms of Education
in terms of funding funding programs
that we've come to the table to agree
upon well thank you for your question
look the Department of Education uh
which uh which is leading on that on on
education and what we're doing to
deliver for young people certainly is a
priority for this President and for the
Department of Education don't have any
specific programs or new programs to
announce from here but that is uh you
know making sure that young people have
the what they need for to have a a good
strong education of course as a is a
priority from for this President let's
not forget the first lady is an educator
herself and she uh and she talks about
that and has done the work as well as
first lady on the things that this
Administration is doing to move to move
that ball forward don't have again don't
have anything specific to share but
clearly it's a priority for us and our
young people across our millions and
millions of young people across the
country to make sure that they have
um you know just and fair opportunities
uh that they should have
okay thank you yeah thanks green um so
I'm gonna ask you about trade
um we're days away now from the
president being two years in office and
there have been no completed trade deals
why not so a couple of couple of uh a
couple things here so when the president
was running he made clear uh that uh we
will invest in American workers and
communities before pursuing new trade uh
deals and this is exactly what we've
been doing you've seen it for yourselves
you've heard the uh heard the
Investments that have been made
especially as you think about
manufacturing coming back uh to the U.S
and that is exactly what we're going to
continue to do so you've seen our
economic agendas for historic recovery
and a manufacturing Boom at home more
than 7 750 000 manufacturing jobs were
created right here under this president
at the same time we were working
we go back and forth on this Ed I I hear
you I'm I'm 750 000 jobs let me finish
your your answer you asked me a question
but at the same time we are working
swiftly to finalize the indo-pacific
economic framework which represents 40
of the world GDP and will address the
core issues that will Define much of our
success in the coming decades like clean
energy energy and the digital economy
while fortifying our economies against a
range of threats from fragile Supply
chains to tax Havens we are committed in
every region of the world to strengthen
trade and investment in a manner that
promotes good paying American jobs
and also high standards and supply chain
resiliency and that has been the
president priority at every step of the
way we will work with Congress to
negotiate and develop trade policies
that Advance the interest of all
Americans support U.S Innovation and
workers and enhance our competitiveness
and that has been the president's uh
priority that is what he talked about
during the campaign and that's what he's
been doing and delivering on for the
past two years go around go ahead April
I'm putting two questions
um you just from the podium and an
answer to one of the reporters you said
something about you don't want to
politically interfere when it comes to
this investigation on the documents I
asked you when we first heard about the
documents there is a political component
and the legal component but can you
expound upon what you don't want to
interfere on political politically
because many pundits many lawyers many
politicians are saying that this is also
an issue that could prohibit a lot of
work in this 100 with 118th Congress a
lot of work for the American people in
this moment could you expound on what
you were talking about
well look I I'm not going to get into
politics from here
um and I've been very clear about that
I've answered that question multiple
times already what I can say is that the
president's going to stay laser focused
on delivering for the American people
and that's going to continue to be the
work that he sees at hand
when it comes to the economy when it
comes to the bipartisan infrastructure
legislation when it comes to
implementing the inflation reduction act
which we announce a couple of items last
week on how important it's going to be
for medicare to negotiate that is
something that is going to be critical
for the American families for American
people across the country being able to
negotiate the price of drugs and tap it
I cap it at uh you know at two two
thousand dollars a year that's going to
make a difference in people's lives
right continuing to do the work that he
has been doing to lower costs and we've
seen that we've seen that the
president's economic plan is indeed
working and so look that is not going to
stop us that is something we're going to
continue to talk about and you're seeing
you're seeing how the work that he's put
in the last two years his administration
the work that he's done with Congress in
a bipartisan way in historic Fashions is
actually working and so that's going to
be our Focus because
and I'm In This Moment
there are Democrats who are saying
they're looking to tomorrow it's a
bright spot for Democrats with the
inauguration of West Moore as Maryland's
first black Governor as the third black
elected governor in the nation uh what
does the president say and what does
this White House say about his elevation
this citizen Who Rose to the highest
Heights in the state of Maryland
especially as he campaigned for him well
the president is very much looking
forward to working with uh Governor Wes
Moore and you know you saw the governor
I don't even know is he a governor elect
yet or has been a governor election I
want to be I want to give him the right
Title Here
uh and you saw you saw Wes Moore
Governor like Westmore and the president
many times over the last several months
they developed a friendship the
president's very much looking forward to
working with him uh and we think it's
important it's important to have that
representation it's important to have
someone as uh you know someone who is
qualified and passionate about the work
as Wes Moore uh be you know be in a
position where he can make a change and
make a difference for male lenders and
so that is critically important uh look
you know there is bright spots uh there
are just if you look across the country
what we saw in state elections and what
we saw with governorships what we saw
and um and and other really key
important States uh State um State
offices it was a bright spot and let's
not forget one of the reasons that we
saw that is because of the president's
plan of president's agenda and what he
was able to set forth for the midterms
remember everyone was talking about the
Red Wave and that didn't happen and that
didn't happen because of the president's
leadership
thank you just want to ask you sir I
just want to ask you about something you
said last week last week you were pretty
insistent that you believed that
President's attorneys did the right
thing do you still believe that yes they
did the right thing when it comes to
making sure that when the documents were
found
they handed it over to the archivist and
it was handed over to Department of
Justice but again Steve I'm going to be
very prudent here I am going to be very
consistent it is an ongoing legal
process not going to say more but the
reason I ask is is that what we now know
the president's Council statement the
president's personal lawyer statement
she had a bit more light on this but
they raised more questions about it
namely the first call that President's
personal attorneys made on November 2nd
was not to the FBI that they had found
what we now know were top secret
documents out in the open the first call
was to officials here at this White
House in the West Wing how is that the
right thing is that the right thing when
you see some if you're a lawyer and
you're you don't have a security
clearance and you see a classified
document shouldn't you call the Justice
Department's National Security office
right away again I'm going to refer you
to the White House counsel's office that
is something for them to answer that is
a very specific question that they
should answer that they will engage you
with engage with on you on this just
like my colleague did for almost an hour
and had this conversation with them it
was about a half hour but let me let me
widen him why is it the matter of this
White House Council to deal with
documents from two administrations ago
these are when I'm talking about
presidential records from this white
house why is this White House Council
involved in this matter at all again
this is something for the White House
Council uh to address I am not going to
address that from here I will refer you
to them and I will refer you to the
special counsel and anything that's that
is specific to this particular issue
we have to folks have to gather okay
folks have to gather I'll see you guys
tomorrow
six times that turned out to be false
are you sorry about that
see you tomorrow
tomorrow